name review welcome to meme review the
most esteemed meme review show of all
time my god
people love baby Yoda it's all over the
news there's a new baby yo the meme
taking over Twitter
oh look he slurp a little soup that is
adorable i slurp little soup this is
crazy baby yoda has conquered the world
what that's so awesome
here's how to order a baby yoda
Frappuccino at Starbucks
if you ever uh neurotically order a baby
yoda Frappuccino at Starbucks you can
joke about the Gulag so that's ok send
them to the Gulag but you know what I
really want to say the island of badness
why everyone is talking about baby Yoda
an adorable enigma in this week's
internet obsession the internet can't
have enough of baby yoga I'm like bruh
this mean it's not good it doesn't have
baby yo they're in it me as I banned
someone for breaking reddit term reserve
service even though I laughed at their
meme ok that one was funny fine me
wondering my my mom is eating sugar with
her nose okay that one is rid of
relatable fine
hentai addiction 4 year old me thinking
one of the cartoon characters damn it
I'm not laughing at this garbage meme a
long time ago in a gallery far far away
the Gabrielle Oh Gauri and I read that
right when you look at yourself in the
monitor at the store I do that I still
do that and I'm 30 some things never
change but can we at least appreciate
the superior version the Obama are we
just gonna pretend that doesn't exist
cuz it kind of bothers me a little bit
maybe Obama is always better and will
always be superior me faking a
stomachache watching my brother go to
school that's so [ __ ] funny I don't
even need to laugh at it underage me
looking at the bouncer like okay well
actually I can relate to this side surf
kick Sidious made a baby Yoda cake
how is this meme not riding itself I
would eat that cake I would love to eat
that cake because then I can eat baby
Yoda finally at last I can eat baby Yoda
oh my god I would cut a baby Yoda like
this that's awesome I can't wait
baby Yoda oh that's good I think the
thing that annoys me about baby Yoda
it's like a transformation of a classic
character but it doesn't make my peepee
heart bow set classic transformation of
a character make a pee-pee heart baby
Yoda no peepee heart it is a kind of a
nice bridge from okay boomer you know
the gen C and millennial whatever it is
called it is a kind of nice break from
all the okay boomer [ __ ] but I don't
like this mean and I'm gonna go ahead
and rate it too so hopefully dies and
I'm gonna go ahead and say my opinion
that I said before I would eat baby Yoda
if that what it takes to get rid of him
if someone came and knocked on my door
right now and said hey you have we had
the baby Oh des we bottom I'm up in oil
we fermented him for three days straight
he's not still gonna taste like [ __ ] but
if you eat him he will go away forever
I wouldn't even hesitate I wouldn't hail
baby Yoda just so we're clear if that
hypothetical scenario ever happens next
meme Papa John it's back if you guys
didn't know Papa John from Papa John's
Pizza meme legend meme icon glorious
person has returned from losing his
position at Papa John's for saying the N
word Papa Papa no Papa no Oh Papa wha
disgusting despicable he came back and
he's sweating my god is he sweating what
is that light the day of reckoning it's
coming according to Papa John I've had
over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days
you're looking at a man who's that over
40 pizzas the last 30 days Jesus Christ
Papa don't do that the reason why he's
doing this it's because he's saying the
pieces doesn't taste it's the same
anymore now that Papa John has left the
company all the sudden you know the
pizzas don't taste the same stay tuned
the pizza day of reckoning is coming at
last I knew it
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
it's such a great quote I've had refer
to pizzas nobody Papa John
Oh God that does not look like sweat bra
before 40 pizzas after 40 pizzas boro
boro after 40 G filled before 40 G
testosterone level 10,000 punished Papa
John fallen legend huh why what why what
Papa said bad word you guys remember
that video where he had this son in I
just feel like watching it cuz it's so
good this is a man that has not had 40
pizzas in 30 days welcome to Papa's
house anyone that's rich can't help us
up doing this you'll never see a poor
man do this come on in this is the
person I have money
this morning we launched worldwide
website that thing in the entrance what
is that you do not need that in your
house papa you had it all Papa you just
couldn't help yourself from saying the
bad bad gonna walk us this I got my best
friend my helper in the house maybe I
wonder if he'll take part in the day of
reckoning I imagine just like all the
Papa John staff have pizzas as shields
crust as swords so excited while the
hard work don't get too excited though
you might say something bad there's Bo
eat 40 pizzas in 30 days or am I just
dragging out this joke at this point
anyway is that all the memes I guess
there's not that many memes Papa John
Pizza gets 5 because it's leaves us
anticipated I can't wait for the day of
reckoning I literally can't wait
reasons not to end it all day of
reckoning of Papa John is coming can't
wait next me
whatever you do do not go to fortnight
burger dotnet trust me don't trust this
man people that went and checked that
fortnight burger dotnet are not happier
after they done it do not search
fortnight burger dot name it's a picture
of a pp just like legit don't do it next
meme alright so last month a lot of
these memes
God why does BuzzFeed after reporting
memes why do you do this well anyway 14
of that oh you like me tweets the right
ridiculously stupidly funny all right
let's see it men be like oh you like
movies name all of them alright this led
to a lot of people copying this format
because it takes no brain effort to come
up with anything funny oh you like book
name old book oh you like euphoria name
every drug these are not funny I'm sorry
you like pop punk name every goddamn
door or your mathematician named every
number okay sure
limb - to infinity I don't remember how
the math was your rich name every number
of your credit card dude in the comments
prove it Megan I'm not writing this all
right some honorable mentions I guess
it's the Statue of Liberty when it was
made
Statue of Liberty now get it because
copper oxidized is that what it's called
in English and it's become green get it
do you understand the joke set you'll
even hear his first made Statue of
Liberty now yeah due to oxidation it
changed to green what the hell was wrong
with people
do they not know this this is a prime
example of construction just why it's
everywhere in my hometown Gothenburg as
well every city every ceiling is green
it's like good job morons
you knew this is gonna happen
another honorable mention is the fact
that getting called baby in public by an
elderly black woman you don't know it's
the most comforting thing ever old white
men calling us sons are just as nice as
old black women calling us baby now
that's the controversial opinion when
cashier calls you honey or sweetheart
you want something all right she wants
some she wants some peepee next me I
don't remember if I reviewed the test
Samim already I feel like I haven't it's
kind of a dead meme but I just think we
should still go through it Hey look
polygon that means funny peepee ha ha I
am Strunk God these are stale my god
these are bad
Ilyn Chandrasekhar make it like this
yeah I've seen a lot of people say this
that this is how they drew cars as kids
idiot Scott Emeril such a [ __ ] this is
how you draw a car as a child okay if
you didn't draw your car like this as a
child then I don't know what to tell you
there must have been something wrong
with you this is how you draw a car okay
God you guys piss me off sometimes
this one is really good did you see died
inside through the conference
no I didn't hey look it's a video game
how I remember games from my childhood
how they actually were okay that's funny
okay that was good
fine that one's good how much does a
polar bear weigh enough to break the ice
you'd think that but no polar bears live
on ice that'd be pretty freaking dumb if
they fell through it all the time I am
smart the hell is this this one is good
tip I'll get to this one advertising the
cyber truck normally turning it into a
meme for free advertising
that's right gamers that's how it's done
free advertising through memes cyka be
at the merch out now epic if you're a
real gamer get it represent back home
slash PewDiePie hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of name review I know the
memes we're not that good this week you
cannot blame me for it when you come up
with still like baby Yoda okay but
that's it for now hey guys for watching
see you tomorrow bye bye we're all
excited about the new game that's coming
out
and I can't wait to play it it starts
with the letter P can you guess what it
is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you